so we'll call the meeting to order this
is
the uh the wrap-up meeting for the
commission to study Advanced nuclear
power um and we have a
very a simple agenda for today's meeting
we're going to uh approve or modify the
minutes from our previous meeting on
November the
6th and then uh we'll discuss the draft
report uh that everybody has in front of
them and if we're comfortable signing
off or we're going to make additional
changes to this so I think those are
those are our
options Mr chair i' move in minutes as
presented all right uh Senator Pearl
moves the minutes and they're in so the
report contains about 50 pages of
content and then an additional 50 or so
pages of all the meeting minutes so this
is a compilation of all of our uh
efforts for for the last year um in one
package so the minutes from the November
sixth
meeting uh start on
page 100
yeah and go to the rest of the
document I'll
second I'll second Senator br's motion
discussion all right all in favor of
approving the November six
minutes I any
opposed all right and that is six of us
so that's a
quorum
all
right so this was an ordeal uh the
subject matter um as we all found out is
pretty intense um and and Matt you know
from working at cab Brook you know just
the the conventional nuclear power
plants are complicated but this kind of
uh breaks the the mold and uh gets even
more complicated with all different
types of fuels and heat transfer mediums
and different sizes of
designs um
so this this report is a compilation of
all the minutes sort of kind of
refactored into subject matter area hey
welcome Mark sorry that's
okay and I think there's one more for
you we did nominate you to be the chair
going any meetings going forward after
computer thank you very
much all right Mark we just took a vote
on approving the November six minutes I
sent those out I think Monday so you
should have a copy of those in
advance all right and now we're just
discussing the final
report I'd give the this is my personal
opinion having done a lot of it is this
is probably a a b effort
if we had a little more time I think I'd
make some tweaks to it um I sent this
out yesterday um which I know is last
minute for a document to size um but
with holidays and I had a trip uh I was
traveling this month so I didn't have uh
all the free time I hoped I
had
um so yeah if you if you've had a chance
to look it over a lot of the material
was in our interim report so we had the
interim report covered meetings up in
till June so we had four meetings since
then so what I went and did was went
back through the different sections and
sort of updated refreshed them to
include more recent information that we
received so I guess if you want a few
minutes just to look it over and then we
can discuss what our next steps
are and I have one extra copy here if
anybody would like to I know Alvin if
like to see
one Mr chair the changes that you made
in update from the interim report are
there's is there a specific section that
those are in so we could review those
yeah so the changes were throughout and
keeping track of the changes the
document just looked like uh got it so I
I I did not do that but okay if we do
make any changes from here on out we
will I don't expect them to be
major um we will track
changes
if the changes are minor I brought my
laptop we
can make tweaks as we go
but so I'll just I'll walk as you guys
are reading it if you don't mind me
talking I'll just walk through the
sections so we have a cover page table
of
contents and then the beginning of the
final report there's an overview of the
commission it references the
commission's uh mandate which is on
appendix a it lists the members of our
commission uh Senator Pearl you replaced
uh Senator Ganon after the new term and
our member from the New Hampshire um
Bureau of uh Department of Business and
economic Affairs uh he he has since
resigned from his position that was Mel
so I did not list him here because he he
wasn't a member for very long um and
then I have uh an executive summary of
and then there's a list of all the
meetings beginning with our October 11th
meeting from last year and there's just
a summary of what we went through um the
different uh presenters that came and
and just a very short outline on what
they presented and then each section has
a link to the meetings in to the minute
meetings in the back if people would
detail and then on page 10 there's an
introduction
gives an overview of advanced nuclear
[Music]
technologies and then the importance of
nuclear in modern power
generation existing nuclear power in ISO
New England so we have a list of some of
the different uh actually there's two
two current plants in is New England and
some that are that have been
shuttered and then there's a list of
recent nuclear energy projects in the US
and there's several there including some
14 I I mentioned the new scale and uamps
and I gave an update on that they've uh
since parted ways uh so a little bit of
overview on that was a going to be a a
first of a Kind project that has gotten
uh
shuttered um new scale did
make an announcement on November the
20th of this year that they have a new
partnership ship with the doe so that
that and then it discusses the nuclear
Enlightenment period that was uh the
American nuclear Society had that
concept that there used to be a nuclear
Renaissance and they they classifi this
as a nuclear Enlightenment and it's more
driven uh
grid talks about some recent movies uh
Oppenheimer and nuclear
now in the next section so that's
popular
culture and then it's it's some
information about our regional energy
markets how
um
broken uh it was yeah well basically
what ISO England kind of presented to us
that the the energy is um coal and oil
are diminishing greatly natural gas and
up then there's a there's a section on
technology and then it talks about some
of the aspects of it like the modular
construction and
transportability the fact that nuclear
has high energy density so there's a
graphic here from the Department of
energy National that talks about
the uranium the size of your the tip of
your pinky finger can replace an entire
ton of coal so it's very high energy
density
medium and it talks about how it's
intermittent and then on page
18 the ability to load follow so these
new designs can ramp up and down to sort
and then it talks about the pass of
Safety
Systems so they they use sort of the
laws of physics
to um shut down safely it's kind of
different from the older style nuclear
power
plants I think we heard in our testimony
Fukushima had an issue because their
generators were below the sea sea
level and those generators were needed
to keep the system in a safe State and
so those generators got flooded
weren't weren't operational and that's
really the main issue that they had so
these new designs don't have that that
uh that
manufacturers and then it talks about
small energy planning zon so I think is
or 10 to 25 mile so a lot of these
manufacturers talk about an emergency
planning zone that's just the footprint
of the of the site you know maybe just a
half an acre or an
acre um and that's still being flushed
out by the nuclear Regulatory Commission
but that's
the um that's the desired uh planning
about and then it talks about carbon
free energy generation that nuclear
provides potential benefits to New
Hampshire's
economy we heard about a national
security implications from not having a
robust nuclear program in our country
that China and Russia uh may be getting
ahead of the US on that and as they
develop relationships with the rest of
the world that sort of cements them as a
leader in the nuclear energy industry
and that um so we have some catch-up to
do
nationally um and there's some National
Security risks if we don't do
that and then it goes into the different
Advanced nuclear reactor Technologies
um it was a little difficult to classify
each different design you know perfectly
under a subheading because some of them
are in multiple categories
but so I'm on page
21 so we we talked about lightwater SMR
so those are more similar to traditional
nuclear power plants but smaller in
scale 550 to 300
megawatts um and then we we listed some
of the
manufacturers that are under that
category
and then there's high temperature gas
reactors uh one in particular that stood
out was X
energy so they have um tof fuel Pebbles
they're called but they look like
billiard balls so they're sort of like a
self-contained fuel packet and there's
hundreds of them in a in a bin that kind
of circulate like a bubble gum machine
and they use hydrogen or sorry helium
gas to cool and to extract the heat from
the process so that would be a high
temperature gas
reactor you anybody want to chime in on
anything should I keep going
okay
yeah
gas um so I have it listed under molten
salt reactors on page
could be
so and if there are any inaccuracies on
this let's let's update it um but my
understanding is they're using molten
salt
um yeah so it's I don't know if it's
that and I can actually I can move it
document and then we heard from molx uh
back in October um and they have an
interesting project where they're
Brunswick they're building a 600
megawatt waste burning reactor and
they're going to collocate it with an
existing nuclear power plant so they're
going to take the waste so we when we
went to Seabrook and we we saw that
building where all the waste is
held um moltex is going to you know in a
similar Arrangement they're going to
build a waste recycling plant um and
then use that waste to power their 600
megawatt reactor so they're recycling
you know slightly used nuclear
Fuel and they're going to run for I
years so that's on pap age 23 so that
was an
interesting
project and then there's something
called a fast Neutron
reactor and there's a little overview of
what that entails on page 24 and uh OKO
was classified as a fast Neutron reactor
and I think they also do something with
uh
recycling they're going to
Fuel and then we heard from several
micro reactor so these are like 1 to 20
megawatt plants that they're their
Market is uh targeted towards like
diesel generators so if you have like a
mining operation somewhere off grid that
uses a lot of diesel fuel to power their
operation these would sort of be like
Drop in replacements for large diesel
ener uh diesel generators so that's
their target not not quite a good fit
for New Hampshire possibly
but um you could you could see
maybe something like in the North
country or you know it wouldn't require
an interconnection so you could put it
in the middle of nowhere so we heard
reactors on page 26 now U we heard from
Ultra safe nuclear they stress a couple
of strategic Partnerships with fratone
and urano for their fuel supply so
there's some links to those companies in
that
section and then we heard from
Westinghouse Westinghouse is connected
to the ap1000 project that is that just
came online in at the Vogal plants so
they have a smaller version called the
ap300 that's uh designed to not
be it's designed to use all the same or
all the similar systems that the ap1000
in vogle uses but scaled smaller and the
idea is that there's not a lot of
technological risk because it's they're
they're they're not uh innovating in any
novel ways they're just kind of scaling
down what they already have online so
thought that was interesting from wesing
house and then it goes into Fusion
reactors so that wasn't in the uh the
statute that we would cover Fusion but
it it's become a recent news item so I
thought it'd be good to at least touch
on it so there's some explanation about
how Fusion is different than
fision and we did hear from for one we
heard from uh Matt Wald who was a
journalist that covers nuclear energy he
talked about it um we heard uh Michael
wiel from the NRC he touched on that the
NRC is going to develop regulations for
Fusion
reactors we heard from Craig pear see
from the American nuclear Society he
talked about Fusion reactors the
consensus is that it's still decades
away um and that the manufa like the
recent um news about Fusion
breakthroughs they're still not reaching
a point where they're getting more
energy out of the system than they put
in um and we heard from zap energy back
in September who's working on a fusion
reactor and they have a novel way that
they're doing it they actually use
electricity to sort of Slam plasma
together to create a fusion event and
then they capture the neutrons released
in liquid metal and then that liquid
metal goes to I guess would
theoretically go to run a steam turbine
energy all right I'll keep going any
anybody else is this helpful to kind of
so then we talk about the nuclear fuel
supply chain so Fuel and regulation were
two big things that are potential
hurdles for this Advanced nuclear
industry so the fuel supply
chain uh there was this idea that kept
coming up called The Chicken and the Egg
problem it's sort of like you know which
came first or which comes first is it
the consumers of advanced nuclear or the
producers of advanced Nuclear So the The
Producers don't want to create a whole
bunch of product that no one's going to
buy and the consumers don't want to
build their reactors without having fuel
to feed the reactor so there like a
chicken and an egg problem it's probably
going to take the government the federal
government to to kind of break that
deadlock um and one of the uh issues is
this Halo fuel production so Halo stands
for high essay low enriched
uranium so traditional Fuel That C Brook
uses I think up to
%
um enriched but the Halo is between five
and up to 20% enrich so it's and I think
for nuclear proliferation you have to
worry about like 90% or higher so it's
still not quite um that level of
enrichment but this Halo is even more
energy dense and a lot of these new
reactors um will use
it and it allows them to run I think up
to eight years without being refueled so
that's uh and CBR I think it's 18 months
right so every 18 months you have to
shut down for maybe four weeks or
something you so these new reactors may
be able to run for much
longer um and there's recent news about
centrus energy they they've just come
online with their pink pipon Ohio plant
they've just started processing some
that and then on page 30 we get into the
Trio fuel technology so Trio takes
little poppy seed like um tiny little
flakes of uranium and some other
materials and they wrap it into a larger
either like a rod or a
ball and the idea is
that um it prevents um radiation uh you
know having an event where radiation can
leak out it's more it's safer not
perfectly safe of course but it's safer
um so that Trio fuel technology is used
in some of these Advan
reactors there's a picture of it on page
30 and then we heard uh continuing with
fuel we heard from
lightbridge and lightbridge is creating
their fuel technology there's a picture
of their Twisted rods that has Trio in
it um those rods are you know a few feet
long it's uh operates at a lower
temperature and this may even be an
option I think for C Brook right that if
you guys uh this may be able to power
like traditional reactors as
well it it could be
disposal and this idea keeps coming up
uh about recycling slightly used fuel um
but there's some questions about whether
it's commercially viable to do that or
not but there are some companies looking
into doing that
and the idea is that the traditional
reactors they use a very small
percentage of the potential energy in
the fuel and
that um you know it had it all been
buried in yucka Mountain miles deep uh
that in the future there may be ways to
like get more energy out of the that
uranium um and so there's there's
companies working on that it could be up
to like a 10 trillion dollar industry if
they cracked the nut of uh recycling
used
field and then we get into
non-electrical applications so that was
in our
mandate and it talks about so if you
have a reactor the reactor most reactors
want to run 100% of the time just crank
out electricity but the rest of the grid
has different uh demands like so demand
goes up and down depending on the time
of day or the season and so what do you
do with electricity that is being
generated but the grid doesn't need it
so what do you do with it and uh you
know you don't want to just waste it you
want to use it for something so so
there's ideas of using it for hydrogen
production so hydrogen would be a type
of stool H sorry type of fuel storage
technology so you would
be hydrogen is more like a battery than
it is um a fuel so you would use
electrolysis to separate the hydrogen
and oxygen atoms and store the hydrogen
to be used later in combustion or fuel
cell or something like that
the radio the radioactive materials can
produce medical isotopes that are useful
for diagnosing and even curing
diseases it could be used for
desalination projects so you could take
sea water and make drinking water from
it and then there was a lot of talk
about industrial heat application so a
lot of uh manufacturing processes like
Metallurgy or
um Chris welcome uh I think there's one
more we have one
that this came off my home printer so it
was like two rings of
paper so Chris just to catch you up we
uh approved the minutes from the
November meeting that's page 100 in back
and now we're just kind of walking
through the I was just kind of Step by
Step so we're on page
34 or actually 3
three and we're talking
about um non-electrical applications for
nuclear energy so industrial heat uh so
there's U large scale manufacturing um I
think some of them are listed here uh
the industrial heat can be used for uh
different sectors like manufacturing
chemical processing food production
metall
orgy it's it's used for things like
drying or melting or smelting or
refining or cooking or sterilizing so
traditionally this has been produced um
this
large scale heat has been uh produced
with fossil
fuels or coal natural gas and oil so
some of these designs have uh
application for industrial heat so it
would decarbonize these processes and it
gets into that a little bit it talks
manufacturers and then this is
uh on page 34 it gets into Data Centers
and we even heard about Bitcoin mining
that's uh you guys probably know that's
a favorite subject of mine so I it's
Chairman's prerogative to uh connect
those two things together um but not
just um turning energy
into uh like a digital commodity that's
one application for it but these AI data
centers like we're all familiar with how
AI is kind of growing they they're very
energy hungry so a lot of these AI um
you've heard of cloud CL Computing with
like Google and Microsoft and Amazon
those very large data centers require so
a computer needs energy to function
right so if you have a lot of computers
it takes a lot of energy and uh a lot of
these data centers they want to be
carbon neutral so they're exploring
using nuclear energy to power their data
centers um and that was confirmed I had
a conversation with the founder of Nano
uh technology uh and he told me that a
lot of these guys are calling him up and
asking um
and will turn your mic on sorry there's
a lot of AC involved there too right
cooling you got to make sure that those
server Farms are kept at at a proper
temperature there's a lot of energy draw
there not just for the processors
themselves right yeah that's that's more
of a question than a statement I that is
I mean from my understanding I I I agree
with it um and there's ways you can air
cool it or you can liquid cool it right
um and I think there's even talk of
using like extracting the heat through
some kind of liquid and then running
like a greenhouse with it so like
reusing it for a different purpose a lot
of those like 350 megawatts of load
continuous load is what I'm hearing for
some of those data centers that's a lot
l so I I mean I think that's uh we're
only going to have more and more
computers running and they all require
energy so give an idea that's about 17th
of new hampsh PE 17 yeah sounds crazy
rough that's just one data center yes
amazing so think about what we would
have to do here to add a data center
right right yeah with our high Electric
market all of the nuclear capacity in
New Hampshire yeah it's one point
1.2 1.2 gws yeah
all right and then it gets into some
risks of of nuclear technology so we
heard a lot about financial risks to
these projects um so it go it goes into
the ways it a project can go
wrong and then it talks about safety
considerations um for the reactors
themselves and there's a lot of concern
about you know what do you do with the
radioactive
waste uh you know how long is the
halflife of this
waste there's a little there's a section
on
understanding radiation so I thought it
was interesting to just touch on um you
know radiation the different types of it
and the fact that we get some radiation
exposure if we fly in an airplane or but
um there's a lot of discussion about how
radiation can be very
harmful and that's something that the
public is very aware
of and then it talks about nuclear waste
waste
management
so 34 states utilize dry Cask facilities
and we saw those at um at seab
Brook so it's a common convention to
store the the waste on
site and we saw that some of these
designs incorporate that into their
design um where they
actually they actually store the casks
as part of their design and then after
maybe 40 or 50 years they have a plan to
sort of reprocess it but that's kind of
like an ongoing not reprocess but store
it
somewhere um but I think uh the whole
concept of intermediate sto storage
somewhere is uh politically not feasible
currently
right
yeah nobody wants it
yeah I was on uh I I heard a uh not
related to this uh
not related to our meetings but there
was a a conference it's it's in one of
our meeting notes the reference to it I
think from the October meeting but there
was a conference uh about uh recycling
nuclear Fuel and they were saying that
because it's consent-based that they
need one Governor somewhere in the
country to consent to receiving the
waste so that they can set up a
recycling uh plant for it so apparently
not one Governor has done that so
but that it could be potentially be a
industry all right and then it talks
about um comparing the risks of nuclear
37 so I actually have a question about
that
yeah so it's is that a terot is that
what tww stands for yeah so how many
terawatts of power do wind versus and
solo do produce versus nuclear because I
mean I see there essentially the same
risk factor yeah only creating one
terawatt in wind and a thousand in
nuclear would could really be a
different scale that's a good question
it is kind of levelized towards how much
they how many ter terawatts they
generate so without knowing the
difference between them it would kind of
risk
per right but you could have one death
in solar and 100 in nuclear and still
have the same per 100 because you don't
know how many terawatts in each are
produced that's a good question is that
something we should add to the report I
don't know just that was me reading it
yeah that's the way my mind work I mean
I'm sure we could come up with another
that and now I'll just keep going here
considerations so there's this new Part
53 that the NRC is working on that would
cover these Advanced nuclear
reactors
um the NRC presentation they're they
seem very enthusiastic about moving this
along but uh the bureaucratic uh inertia
is sort of holding it back
right
and then on page 39 we had uh
presentations from different Federal uh
program so we had a presentation from
Chris Los of the gain program and gain
stance for Gateway for
Accelerated Gateway for Accel
accelerated innovation in
nuclear and so he presented on the uh
the voucher system that's part of the
gain program so that could be um they
have vouchers valued up to
$500,000 with a 20% cost share and
there's different details in that
section but that could be a resource for
our
state and then we heard from Julie
karaki from the doe loan programs office
and her presentation was pretty uh dense
with
information so I'll just pause here on
on the top of page 40 she talked about
the cost ranges
I went back through all of our old
minutes and I wasn't able to get like a
consistent uh you know chart of all the
different uh cost estimates from the
different
manufacturers
and I sent out a survey this might may
be an addendum to our report at some
point but see if I can pull it up
here I've only gotten four
responses
and I don't know why it's not
it could
someone push the button on the remote
so
there we
sleep that's my screen yeah I just
wanted to show you I I sent out a survey
to the different manufacturers I've
received
some
here yeah sure yeah welcome if this is
just be a
minute and actually it probably won't be
so everybody see that so this is a
survey we're still compiling results so
i' I got another response today it looks
like so I have five responses
um this is not in the report because
it's not uh we didn't get responses in
time and there's some I still have to
track down but basically you know who
they are what stage is their is their
current design is it less than 50
approximately 60 around 90 fully
complete um how do you
anticipate uh how long do you anticipate
it will take to to commence construction
after the design phases complete and
there's different date ranges do you
have plans to build a pilot plant for
your projects demonstration project how
do how do pilot plants contribute to the
success of scaling up to a commercial
unit significantly moderate minimal that
kind of responses if if applicable have
you secured a site or partners for the
demonstration project yes uh and then
there's various uh yes maybe no with
that kind of
thing engagement with the nuclear Reg
tour commission how would you describe
your interaction with the NRC in
preparing for following a license
application highly interactive
moderately interactive limited
interaction we have not yet
interacted what type of feedback or
questions have you received from the NRC
about your design detailed general
questions about safety and regulations
we have not received feedback or
questions and then uh when do you expect
to have your first non-nuclear con
construction permit from the NC when do
you expect to have your first nuclear
construction permit approved by the
NC how suitable is their design to New
Hampshire um these are just it aligns
forth range in dollars so there's the
question that I asked range in dollars
per megawatt
hour and then any additional information
so just briefly here I'll I'll click on
the responses I'll go to that
question so we
have so we can compile this as sort of
like an addendum if we get complete
information um but I did want to look
at the range here in megawatt hours so
I've only gotten two
responses and they range between 80 and
120 and then one response is $200 per
megawatt
hour so I couldn't tell you W without
digging into it who who those responses
came from
but so going back to page 40 the top of
the page there um Julie karaki gave us
an approximate cost range so in $23 she
says 66 to$ 109 doar per megawatt hour
and then she says by
2050 they expect that to go down to 58
to $79 per
meat so this response here the 80 to 120
is a little bit more in line with what
Julie said but a little
higher so that we talked about this at
our last meeting um that's the best
response I could give you
but but Julie's
uh presentation had a lot of that
information in it so we capture it here
on page
40 and they expect approximately they
need approximately 200 gws of new
nuclear generation if the us is going to
transition away from
carbon so that's a a pretty big number
Generation and then we heard from Dr
Billy valderama from the
Department from the office of nuclear
energy from the
doe and he he kind of uh affirms some of
the other things that were said
prior and I'm looking at the bottom of
page 40
here um he also referenced
the new scale power module at uh in
Idaho in his presentation and I added a
little caveat there at the very end
happening and then on page 41 he talks
about this Marvel project uh it's 100
kilowatt micro reactor it's going to be
deployed at the Idaho National
Laboratory by the end of 2024 and I
page uh let's see page 13 there was a
project and then he talks about the four
main priorities of the office of nuclear
of nuclear energy so they want to
maintain the existing reactor Fleet they
want to deploy new Advanced reactors
they want to ensure secure nuclear fuel
supply chain and they want to expand
International
cooperation and he mentioned the
advanced nuclear State collab
collaborative and I put a note to myself
that there should I should have expanded
that uh some detail on that
but um that would be an interesting
pursue and then the next section this is
pretty much the same as our interim
report uh the recent federal policy
initiatives so it talks
about some different Federal uh
legislation that is related to Advanced
Nuclear So we have the nuclear energy
Innovation and modernization
act and that was signed into law by
President Trump in
2019 we have the infrastructure
investment and jobs Act of 2021 that had
some
uh it had some Provisions for nuclear
energy
energy within its
total uh 2.5 billion is earmarked for
Technologies and I'll we're on page 42
now um the inflation reduction Act of
2022 had some aspects that applied to
Advanced
nuclear and then the chips and science
Act of 2022 also
um had some provision Visions for
Nuclear So it authorize $390 million to
establish up to four new research
reactors and nuclear science and
engineering
facilities then we have the
2023 and then we have the Strategic
nuclear infrastructure
act I don't know that one was signed
into
law and then continuing we had a recoup
American nuclear Global Leadership
act and then accelerating deployment of
versatile Advanced nuclear for clean
energy the advance act that was a
bipartisan group of
2023 it passed the US Senate as part of
2023 and then we have uh some topic
about there's organized opposition uh to
to nuclear that is longstanding in our
area and we have
uh uh a representative from Beyond
nuclear here is that right you work for
Beyond nuclear okay you're just you're
friends with Paul g g okay that's that's
I just made the assumption
and so it talks about I'm sorry go
ahead that your
friends okay all right it's also one of
my
constituents oh excellent oh very good
actually I have two constituents with
constituents all right so it talks a
little bit about the clamshell Alliance
that we uh have heard so much about they
were formed in 1976 and they opposed the
construction of C Brook nuclear power
plant um there was an event where large
a large protest with civil
disobedience and I think something like
1400 activists were arrested is that
sound
right 15 okay 145 more importantly
they oh yeah you had to go through
the um and then they were ultimately
unsuccessful in stopping Seabrook
totally but there there was only one um
reactor developed I think partly because
of financial reasons but some because of
opposition
right and then there's the C10 research
and Education Foundation that's funded
mainly by um Massachusetts if I
understand correctly the C10 they
operate radiological monitoring Network
around
cook so they they get activated if
something goes wrong right C
Brook okay all right I won't put you on
the
spot and then it talks about Beyond
nuclear which we've had Paul Gunter from
Beyond nuclear has participated in many
of our
meetings um and they're out at tol Park
Maryland and so they're looking
to
um if I understand it and you correct me
if I'm wrong they want renewable energy
and they don't want nuclear right is
that kind of the yeah so they're kind of
I don't want to say anti-nuclear but
they would rather nuclear not
proceed okay all right so anti- nuclear
would be accurate um but they focus on
policy and advocacy so they're active in
our state as
well all right and then we move on to
there needs to be if this is going to
proceed further public engagement is
important and you know how do we do that
how do we engage publicly in this area
and there's a few ideas in in those
paragraphs
there and then just I probably have
another 10 minutes and then I'll I'll be
wrapped up um sorry to put you to
sleep we heard from ISO New England um
they put on a presentation to us and it
was uh Eric Johnson presented to us on
October he talked a lot about the
changing Energy Mix in the region um it
sounds like a lot of the our surrounding
states our neighbor states are pushing a
lot of green energy policy on ice and
New England they're neutral they don't
take a position um but they do follow
what states tell them to do um and so if
New Hampshire has a different idea we
have to be a little more assertive with
Isa New England uh to kind of
counterbalance what our neighboring
states are doing you know if our
policies are different and they seem to
be I think uh I think I heard our
consumer Advocate on TV call us the uh
the redheaded stepchild of I or
something because our state thinks
differently than other states don't
quote me on that but he said something
like that um but so Eric Johnson went
into uh you know how our energy grid is
transitioning the challenges of
renewable because it's uh renewable just
tends to be intermittent and it you know
in the winter time we can't have the
power go out because people might freeze
to death and uh that would
be not a good situation so he talks
about you know the need for base load
power he says he talked about the
interconnection cue he gave us kind of
like a an overview of how
interconnection uh how the new ones come
online and he said that there's about
38,000 megawatts of predominantly
renewable energy working its way through
that interconnection que process that's
Regional so that was an
interesting
see so their assumption ice New
England's assumption is that no new
nuclear plants will be constructed in
the region over the next 40 years so
that's their assumption that they're
operating on so if if this Advanced
nuclear industry gets off the ground
that assumption would need to change
right so um so it was kind of good to
connect with icea New England on this
topic and then we have I mentioned our
consumer Advocate we had Donald Cree he
presented back in our May
meeting he reminded us uh he said people
think that he's anti-nuclear but that's
not the case and early in his career he
was involved with the Vermont Yankee
plant he was I think def he was
defending the plant against aggressive
actions by the state of Vermont and he
said he thought that was wrong that the
state told the plant that it had to shut
down so that was
interesting but he said in his position
neutral well and that our state in
general is technology neutral
um he said adding it adding nuclear to
ADV to renewable standards could be an
option um but he said
his his role as consumer advocate he has
to consider who Bears the cost of any
potential new nuclear generation so he's
very uh he he guards the rate pair from
having additional burdens and risks put
on them so that would rule out any kind
of large scale subsidies by the state uh
you know he would be likely opposed to
that all right so the last couple
sections
findings I think we going to slow down a
little bit just because I think these
deserve a little extra attention the key
findings and then the potential State
policy options so let's uh it's only a
page and a half but let's go through one
at a time and see if we want to cross
off anything or expand
anything um because I think this will be
the section that people kind of flip
to and then after that we just have the
conclusion which is basically a summary
of everything we just talked about
so you want to take a minute just to
read those let's start with the summary
of key findings and just put your
thinking caps on and see if there's
anything
missing
um read first yeah do you want me to
read
it um you want to read it you want me to
read it out loud or do you want to just
read
it however you want to do it
yeah oh well let's go through them one
at a time then you want to read them
sure
guess
okay signant
it's yeah
achieving that
zero without nuclear okay so that came
from one of our presentations they were
talking about I think it was Julie
kazaros presentation she was saying like
if nuclear is not part of the mix then
the costs just go through the roof but
you're right it approaches
impossibility so you want to make that
statement a little stronger I I would
just question the feasibility of
something like that point out that it's
about you could just simply add limiting
use could significantly escalate the
cost of carbon
reduction efforts and feasibility with
current
Technologies and feasibility with
limiting its use canly escalate the cost
of carbon reduction
efforts potentially making it infeasible
right's
okay I'm G to just write this in my
it all right then number
two uh nuclear energ reliability and
efficiency
iner reliability and efficiency of power
add so you mentioned earlier about you
know
new reactor technology has the ability
to load follow right well generally what
we have in this country can't load
follow right C can't load follow it's a
Basel plant they fire up it runs that's
I mean unless I'm wrong I know you have
can I you can move a little bit but yeah
I think cook probably could load follow
I think economically it's not viable the
way that they sell okay it could put
like additional stresses on the whole
system right if you change the love the
fuel fuel could you put your mic
on I believe that the fuel is what gets
stretched if you you try to load follow
I don't think it's an issue with the
fuel it's purely I think it's purely
economics I understand because
everything is designed around months so
they put a certain of fuel so you know
there are challenges up and down I think
it could be done technically technically
it's okay did you want to make a change
to number
two well given that I don't know maybe
not
um so it talks about grid stability that
that's sort of the main point there is
that right
yeah that's an important feature that we
yep okay with number two number three
progress in nuclear fuel recycling the
development and implementation of spent
nuclear fuel recycling methods are
important important steps forward in
management so I have notes to myself
after I read it
again talking like adding something
about economic
viability and and
uh avoiding proliferation
risk so I think adding those two things
to that one would round it out works is
right all right uh number four
Innovation and nuclear business models
the emergence of innovative business
models for advanced nuclear technologies
is a notable Trend such as the power as
model so several of these manufacturers
talked about they would continue to own
the plant and they would uh basically
sell the power to customers so they
would be responsible for any maintenance
and ultimate decommissioning of it it
seems very uh
ambitious but that's what several of
them
said understand need to change
it it's good to go
okay number five modernizing nuclear
licensing
processes efforts are underwear to
update and streamline the nuclear
reactor licensing process focusing on
achieving a balance between flexibility
should we say something in there about
still ensuring safety and all of that
that the Regulatory Commission pointed
out yeah while while
ensuring
safety I yeah I agree with that that's
really the nrc's main job right to maybe
focusing on achieving a balance between
flexibility safety and predictability or
something like that just to keep it
simple can you balance three things yeah
that's
problem all right I'll add safety in
there between flexibility and
predictability uh number six learnings
from Advanced nuclear projects key
lessons include the importance of
complete design development before
construction collaboration with
experienced contractors and ensuring a
robust supply
chain so we had uh was it wesing house
they talked a lot about Lessons Learned
From the Vogal plant because that went
way over budget and uh it was eventually
successful but in economic terms it was
uh you know big big cost overruns and so
they
said a little bit I mean if you if if
you average it out over 80 years maybe
it's not so much but yeah over the life
of the plant that's going to be a it's
going to be valuable but from a net
pressent value basis yeah yeah but they
talked a lot about their um some of
their Partners in that project were not
as uh experienced as they maybe could
have
been and that's the
whole it's kind of a separate chicken
and an egg thing is
that you need a lot of uh High skilled
labor to build these projects they're
not being built for decades and so how
do you kind of start up that whole
experience you know cycle I don't know
this is where you'd want to put it but
then they talk about if you're the first
of the of its kind and You' make first
of a kind of 20 different projects
you're not going to save money but you
have to find one that and go with it
kind of thing I don't know if this is
where you want it but or if you talked
about that somewhere else would you put
that there so like achieving nth of a
kind I think is the term they would use
right
yeah so you get uh efficiencies
economies of scale if you're like if
you've ever put together an Ikea
bookshelf or done something first of a
kind in your house you know you like the
first time takes
you five hours and you do it wrong but
the second time you do it you can do it
like that
right I think that might fit under
number
for okay yeah actually let's put it
that
um seven Advanced reactors combining
novel Technologies Innovative reactor
designs are being developed combin high
temperature operations thermal energy
safety good yeah I mean it's it's a
generic statement y eight uh goal for
cost trist with fossil fuels there was
an industrywide goal to make adance
nuclear reactors cost competitive with
fossil fuel power plants without relying
on
subsidies so we heard that from several
manufact I'm sure they'd all love
subsidies if they could get them but we
sort of said that we're not friendly to
subsidies so I think some of them may
have tored their presentation to us you
know um so that last part of without
relying on
subsidies I think that that reflects at
least several of the presentations that
we
heard everybody good with that
one uh number nine Target for commercial
deployment by
2030 uh many in the industry claim
excuse me uh aim to achieve commercial
deployment of advanced reactor
Technologies by 2030 or earlier I think
that reflects the camera plant right I
think they're that's one I think they're
2028 I know the coal plant's going to
25 let's
see
2030 I think is a good that's Terra
power that's on page
2025 it doesn't have a date for when
they're coming online I think 2030
reflects a lot of what we've heard most
of them
right we we've heard some say late 2020s
but we know how these dates tend to slip
right so
all right uh number 10 emphasis on high
efficiency electricity generation
Advanced reactors are being designed to
efficiency
so yeah what do we mean is that like
heat is that a heat rate thing is that
like a getting more
energy out of the fuel than potentially
some of the older plants do and mattt I
don't know if you want to expand on that
but yeah so like like the gas plants
that run at a higher temperature can get
more fuel out or more energy out um I my
personal opinion is it might dilute kind
of the rest of the findings that my
recommendation you take it out I agree
take it out all right
yeah could it be changed to say the
modular and smaller reactors allow for
localized energy generation which will
improve efficiency a lot of it's lost in
the lines right it's but it's not about
the line I don't think getting at it's
not about transmission line losses here
it's about efficiency of the reactor the
or the in a case of a gas plant the
thermal right extracting is more energy
out of the fuel than the energy loss in
right right
exactly so should we cross it I would I
would in my opinion I would would get
rid of it because you're you're opening
up discussions to like I said about heat
rates right like the most efficient
natural gas plants are like 60%
efficient okay huh yeah so
right the G turbine all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna scratch number
10 yeah
yeah
right want to go to 11 11 okay sorry
yeah good awesome um 11 strategic
approaches to reactor velopment
strategic development approach
prioritizing rapid learning and
industry again very generic yeah I think
that works and number 12 commitment to
commercializing Advanced nuclear is a
broad commitment to the
commercialization of advanced nuclear
technology signaling a potential
sector and the only thing I would say do
we want to add like partnering with you
know large energy consumers because we
know you know like you talked about with
the data centers they're looking that is
something they're actively looking into
you know large industrial consumers
looking at Advanced reactor
technology or do you think that's
already covered I think that might be
its own what if we replace number 10
with that thought where large data
centers are looking I would like large
industrial uses or heavy or high load or
you know I don't know however you want
to phrase it but big energy consumers
are looking at Advanced nuclear because
like a lot of them want to be carbon
neutral
okay like the the new
core you know new scale mou is an
example of that I don't know where
yeah
all
right would you want to include broad
bipartisan commitment because it seems
like both sides are pushing legislation
that is assisting in this or is that not
what your point was in inv it makes it
political at that
point are we could add something about
that back in the section that talks
about uh the different legislation yeah
um because I I'll go through and see who
the sponsors are but I'm pretty sure
there's example I mean the inflation
reduction Act was yeah pretty much the
Biden Administration but it was by
Parson I could put is that a right
there if it's not there already let me
here so are you referring in 12 to
between the the reactor producers and
energy users would you plan to
get yeah that's a good
point
um hey Keith yeah on 12 maybe change it
from broad commitment to Broad
interest okay because I'm not sure that
there actually has been any Financial
commitments made
okay
yeah so
of was page 41 recent federal policy
initiatives I'll just I'll add the word
bipartison in there is that all right
and I I'll find a good spot
blow and what I'll do is
is I'll track changes on the word
document I'll update based on what we
discussed here I'll circulate the track
changes so you can see exactly what's
different um and then we'll release it
r and if you have Mark if you have
suggested language you know we'll throw
that in there
right so last I heard was will change
commitment to interest on number 12 yeah
okay
I I had a couple other items that just
for General consideration so one would
be um we had a lot of talk of
deregulated versus regulated markets and
how most likely any new nuclear is going
to be in a regulated market at least at
the beginning is that worth including in
this section um it's you know it's in
one of
section so it's covered in the consumer
Advocates section um
and
then in the most
recent
um I want to say it was mol's
presentation not molx um Ultra safe
nuclear they
mentioned trying to figure out where it
is in the
document they mentioned that um I'll
have to search for it he mentioned that
most likely it'll be in a vertically
Market first right yeah that's I'm just
wondering if you're saying okay well the
customer for this report if you said
okay what do I want them to take away
one of the things is you know most
likely you're not going to get a new
nuclear plant in a deregulated Market by
the 23ds you're going to be much later
you're going to be nth of a Kind versus
first of a kind once there's more
certainty and you know utilities
like
yeah I mean unless it's privately funded
right yeah I mean
um if if I understand David like if we
had approval for a micro reactor say
let's say let's say it's commercially
available you could put one on your
industrial site somewhere in New
Hampshire as long as it was approved by
like there's
no it would just be a funding an issue
soting there's no prohibition I think
what I don't want to speak what you're
asking is there's no prohibition on an
industrial consumer entering into a PPA
with a
generator right so I mean that's a
possibility but it's kind
of low probability
right all right do you want to we'll put
something
about the likelihood of first of a Kind
going into a regulated market
as opposed
to yeah I don't feel super strongly
about it so if the rest of the
commission doesn't think of arms there
I'm it just seemed to me that it might
be
relevant we had a few people make that
point um you're seeing it with almost
everything right now right so I think
that's fair I offshore wind utility
skill solar none of those are getting
built on Market Revenue they're all
getting built in you know
PPA you know State States supped
contracts okay so I think that's a fair
statement to make all right I'll I'll
draft something up when I can sit and
think about it and then but it'll it'll
I'll go back through and see what uh
different comments were made I think
representative Harrington couldn't be
here today he he has some thoughts on
that
so um and he he's brought up that point
a few times I'll go back and look
exactly what he said
all right any other items and the key
findings we'll update
those all right so last um or before we
get to the
conclusion um we'll look at potential
State policy
options Mark do you want to read through
those yeah I'll keep going okay um an
act legislation for clean nuclear energy
uh designate nuclear as a clean
technology under renewable portfolio
standards and other state clean energy
programs aligning with New Hampshire
Department of energy 2021 State energy
strategy on page
56 there's a link in the document that
goes to their energy strategy if you
want I can pull up what they
said these aren't necessarily
recommendations from us right Keith
these are just we're just throwing out
options you know some options that right
policy makers could take a look at
exactly right I mean that's really all
we can do anyway right we're not making
any solid recommendations okay this is
our preferred Apple
uh well let's go through the whole list
and see I don't think
there's we're kind of limited in what we
can do um and actually there's a few
pieces of legislation that match up to a
but
right uh two feasibility studies for
advanced reactor sites conduct studies
to identify suitable sites for advaned
reactors focusing on potential
applications and end users like
industrial facilities or retiring coal
plants yeah so the the feasibility
studies could be done by maybe the
department of energy or we talked about
Dartmouth is potentially going to look
at some of these things
um I don't know if you have any thoughts
recommendation
my concern would be get you're getting
utilities involved with you know load
capabilities and what they might need to
do to upgrade their systems is that
going
to be costly to them time consuming to
them or do you think it can be done
without involving each I guess that's my
question do you think that something
like this could be done without
involving
utilities you know or feasibility
studies and that sort of thing so that's
kind of something that would have to
probably be approved by the Pu so some
of these Federal programs like retiring
coal plants we have one coal plant in
our in our state um they're looking
for um that specific situation and
they're will nuclear right they're will
the coold nuclear transition they're
willing to help out with that so we'd
have to investigate to see exactly what
resources are available but that may be
one one
me is that all right okay Financial
incentives for nuclear projects identify
potential federal financial support
through grants loans and tax credits
facilitate Advance reactor
demonstrations of deployments while
being mindful of potential political
resistance IND
the so this is uh the free Federal Money
Tree you know like
um I guess it's it's it's something that
we could pursue
potentially I know we're we're stingy
except for when the federal government's
going to give us
to well policy could be um you know
Department's pursuing it right the
executive branch could pursue it seems
like that's a good question actually I
mean it seems like they would be doing
isn't that more of a private sector ini
state could be through like a state
State University or something like that
if it was like the gain program
specifically used for research so if it
was like dth or un or something like I
don't I'm out of my my depth of
knowledge but I I think potentially it
could be yeah I mean
that like like similar to you it sounds
good what you're
saying do we want to modify what we're
saying in that instead of identify then
it maybe utilize potential federal
financial support
maybe I don't
know identifying would be the first step
yeah to go find
right that's the effort to find
right like drill down in that one area I
I don't have a problem with keeping it
but I understand what Center Pearl's
getting
at maybe you could combine that with
number
s
coordin
so number seven when we get to it that
has been in state statute for that's
right decades and I I had um
um someone someone uh in the governor's
office looked into it for me and it
hasn't been filled since like 2007 the
position and the person that was in it
last passed away so we can't even talk
to them they've never yeah so I don't
know if David seen my my bill yet
um you're not allowed to say it hasn't
been released yet but there's a bill to
sort of like update that section and and
put it under the department of energy
which think would be a good home for it
um and it would so the coordinator was
supposed to inform the governor and the
executive counsel like twice a year for
going back to the 50s I think and that
hasn't been done so I think if I recall
correctly I put in like a fiveyear cycle
where it would be you
know sure
sure you're
right so then my my other so when I when
I present Bill I'm going to say if you
don't want to do this then repeal the
statute
because nothing uh bothers me more than
statutes that aren't followed it like so
anyway it's it's a discussion I'm sure
we'll have but that's number seven
to so you were saying combine those two
well if you're going to have you know a
development coordinator one of the
duties be to seek out find available
potential grants
there kind of be a task of this more
Poli
so I'd have to go look at what the
statute actually
says um I mean I'm okay you can this
just do you want to put it can I move it
after that one so if I move three to
like number
eight and then kind of refer back to the
previous
combine I I don't Keith I'm okay yeah
I'm just trying to think like thinking
is
I guess I kind of want to keep it but I
I'm okay it's sort of like a I don't
have any harsh you hard objection to it
or anything it's question we had the
conversation okay but I'll move it till
after seven and that way it's sort of
and I'll reorder connect connect them
all because they do they do seem
related I just kind of see that as like
if this is going to happen that's going
like uh number four Workforce
Development and public awareness
Implement Workforce training programs
public awareness campaigns Foster Talent
pipelines and increase public
understanding of nuclear
technology you would probably have the
biggest on this one yeah I think you
know in industrywide whether it's
utilities or the nuclear Regulatory
Commission there there's a talent
shortage out there for people with
engineering degrees or backgrounds in
this and because most of the plants were
built in the 70s and 80s a lot of the
workforce that work for 30 plus years or
retiring so it's it's definitely
something that if this industry is going
to grow there's there's a shortage
attempt for
yeah do do you see there being issues
down the road with just
having the labor to support the plan
itself operationally don't or is that
not something you're concerned about
right now no I would say like the like
like craft workers like electricians
mechanics and stuff we have those people
it's more you know engineers and you
know people that work in the control
room typically have engineering degrees
where they come out of a nuclear
Navy yeah the industry is uh struggling
to
one number five streamline licensing and
permitting
processes simplify and expedite Advanced
reactors licensing and permitting
processes reducing regulatory
delays is the state policy or is that
state the like the state has its own
um atomic energy statutes right they're
sort of they're tied to the federal
statutes so I don't know David do you
have any thoughts on is
that from a licensing perspective that's
a federal thing I think right I mean the
state's not going to license a facility
does it or does it I don't think it
licenses a facility but there is there
is like you know the Department of
Environmental Services or there's other
stuff that the state does interface with
sighting that' be more permitting right
not licensing per se or you think
there's
overlap
yeah
hey David would you mind just turning
your mic on and just repeating what you
what you said just because it's being
streamed that's all so
I I would have to go back and check but
I do think I would have to go through
the sighting process with the site
evaluation committee and that process is
streamlined so some of these
recommendations came from our
discussions but
it while you looking I'll just say this
I I don't see any problem with number
five whether we really have a lot of
State Licensing control or if it's more
permanent I don't think the statement is
wrong I think it's fine we want line
whatever involvement we
have ums For Me Maybe it's not in my
copy do you guys have one that talks
something the Nei what I'm trying to
find the Nei there it is number
nine can I see that a
isn't mine is from an old toner
cartridge you guys I got the got the
new so the Nei has a whole list of
recommendations for policy and some of
these came from those
suggestions and there's a link in the
digital copy that goes to their document
it has a whole bunch of different
recommendations that that's that's what
I wanted to just point out that that
recommendations
number six invest in nuclear supply
chain
capabilities promote public and private
investments in the nuclear supply chain
manufacturing so we probably want to
scratch out public or and then maybe a
different word besides
promote encourage
encourage I mean the governor does
ribbon cuttings all the time right like
there's promotion of Private Industry by
state
um so you want to say
encourage take out the word
public okay public sorry so number six
Investments encourage private
investments in the supply chains
inment yeah I don't know we're going to
make any public investment as a state
into it I would agree with it yeah so I
mean public could be the federal
government and we know that this is a
national
security you know you know there's
National Security implications for
building up the but it's not a state
policy
right I guess there'd be no issue with
leaving public and in that case we can
encourage it with a resolution or
something if we change can encourage it
if you change to promote encourage
whatever I could add the word Federal in
a I mean it goes back to Federal
incentives right if there's Federal
incentives to you know expand rail or
port or you know whatever for
manufacturing
facility the state depart not got to say
no to no again we got to remember these
are just
options it's an option that we can
encourage it so I I
don't we're not me you know we're not
saying the state should do this we're
just saying the state could look out for
opportunities to do it
right all right how however you want to
word that's okay with okay number seven
appoint a state nuclear development
coordinator revive the coordinate of
atomic development activities position
from a 1955 State Statute to advise and
manage pronuclear policies and
initiatives guiding the legislature
government yeah I I could pull up that
statute if you guys want um
I mean it's one of the few things that
we sort of uncovered in
our it's it's long been forgotten about
I I
believe the fact that it's in our
statutes
have
is a coordination of studies I think
I the governor and Council shall appoint
the head of one of the state departments
concerned as advisor to the governor
with respect to Atomic Industrial
Development within the state as
coordinator of the development and
Regulatory activities of the state
government relating to the industrial
commercial uses of atomic
energy as a deputy of the governor in
matters relating to atomic energy
including participation in the
activities of any committee formed by
the New England
states to represent their interest in
such matters and also cooperation with
other states and with the government of
the United States the department head so
appointed shall have the additional
title of coordinator of atomic
development
activities and there's a few
UH responsibilities there
so that's what that's related to and if
um I think it's just good to have a
discussion about it right it's in
statutes let's uh updated or eliminate
right
that all
right number eight legislation to update
atomic energy statutes draft and
proposed legislation to update the
state's atonic energy statutes
incorporating the federal definition of
advanced okay so I have a bill submitted
I think you're a co-sponsor on it um am
I so we heard from one of
the it could have been Nei I think it
was Nei they they suggested that there's
a federal definition of advanced
nuclear I don't know if I could pull it
up I'll tip my fingers but it has a
whole list of advanced
nuclear and to tie our state statutes to
that
definition putting it in our state
statute so that there's an anchor point
so for like any future legislation it's
it's part of the part of our statutes so
in that update there's a a minor refresh
to our
statutes uh and that's included in that
bill hasn't been released yet but number
nine consult State policy Suggestions by
Nei uh nuclear energy Institute or Nei
compiles reports on potential State
policy options for States as support
nuclear
energy yeah so just real quick there's a
link in the document that goes to
that and
um you know we hear legislators talking
about promoting nuclear and this would
be a good place for them to look in this
document
here I don't know how to make it full
screen but it talks about policy options
and again they're they're not
all so State climate and reduction
policy State energy
policy energy planning
okay Capital
markets transmission
infrastructure so it's a nine-page
document um that's fairly
recent this points people to that
document
perfect uh number 10 reevaluate New
Hampshire's participation in the NRC
agreement State program the NRC assist
States in establishing programs to
assume regulatory Authority Under the
atomic energy Act of 1954 allowing
states to license and regulate various
materials this assistance includes
reviewing requests for agreements
conducting training and evaluation and
coordinating event according with
agreement states currently 39 states
have such agreements including the
Aire so re-evaluate
um I don't know if there's much
discussion about this in the department
of energy or in the Pu I mean does this
here so this goes to the nrc's website
they have a page about New
Hampshire there's a link in the
electronic document that goes to this
about so so
augustinus an is that currently a person
in the department of he's the
administrator of radiological health
health section Department Public
Health I can't read it from here is that
public health let's see if I can make is
that public health is that what you're
talking
about yeah this is the information on
there it is yeah it's Department of
Public Health at the health
services
correct and here's a link to our this is
the agreement that our state has signed
NRC so the idea is maybe we need to go
back and you know ref familiarize
ourselves with this
um is that a good idea okay and you know
maybe um there's resources through those
uh number 11 urge the NRC to review and
approve licenses State Legislature could
pass resolutions urging the nuclear
Regulatory Commission to not delay
license approvals for advanced nuclear
projects so this would be you know just
one of those uh house resolutions that
go into the circular file somewhere in
DC but it could uh you know raise
awareness about
uh number 12 urge Isa New England to
seek Advanced nuclear
proposals while Isa New England remains
neutral on energy generation it does
take direction from Member State policy
cubes so this was Dick Barry's
suggestion he he you know di dick I
served on the science technology and
energy committee when he was the
chairman and he's very knowledgeable
about the stuff he his thought was why
don't we tell all of New England to uh
to pursue pursue this stuff and I don't
know if we can do that or not but I mean
you could put it in here but there's
there's no mechanism for them to like
push one technology really over another
they approve tariffs
and manage markets I mean
that's so our neighboring states are
pushing carbon you know Net Zero policy
right
and we're sort of getting muscled around
by those other markets um I guess if we
said Net Zero has to include nuclear
Advanced nuclear and put that into the
conversation regionally is that is there
a way to do that see what I mean aren't
the other states pushing it through
subsidies to the to the solar and wind
which makes their economics on ice on
New England look better so probably
through that mechanism not necessarily
through the polic itself I mean that's
how they're that's how they're doing it
that's what I said earlier it's that
none of
those none of the wind farms that have
been built in Maine even the ones in New
Hampshire are relying on ppas you know
and all the offshore wind
contracts I think between two developers
they just paid $100 million do in
penalties to get out of the
agreements because finan is not working
so it's
all out of Market you know as far as
what's getting developed right now on a
large
scale okay anybody I mean if
anybody sees anything
differently that's all I
see this I'll add I think I I agree I
think um I think the overarching
encouragement I New England could still
happen we could write letters and we
could we could encourage them to um to
consider the New Hampshire position
which is different I think than the
other states uh but I also agree that
ultimately it's a PPA somebody has to
pay for the technology so both things
are true okay would you modify that or
eliminate it that number 11 or 12 I'm
sorry yeah I mean I I'd keep it I mean I
think encouraging ISO New England is
different than getting a result from ISO
New England so letting them know what
our state policy is and the direction
we're going they want to please us and
so they'll be um interested in our
position but um it's also true that they
they uh they respond to ppas and and and
that's that's how they do business okay
so I think both things are true I I
would I would leave it in there you
leave it in okay and any caveats I mean
I put they they're neutral and they take
direction from Member State
policy that's true it's true yeah yeah
yeah so I mean there may be ways to
assert if our policy direction is
different than our surrounding states if
we just a little more assertive with it
um just to make sure that our interests
are I think that's
right last one number 13 declare nuclear
energy in the
state's national interest State legisl
pass resolutions nuclear energy to be in
the state and
National again another resolution but I
don't know El you guys are the
legislators so if you want to go for it
you there's two resolution items in
there do you have any thoughts on those
13 13 and what was the other
one 11 11 and 13 are kind of related
other well we certainly can if that's
what we decide
that we can certainly uh create
resolutions if that we decide that's the
interest of the state and what we want
to put forward so I I don't disagree
with either state
okay and if we're signaling that we're
friendly to the these businesses I think
that's an important Market signal um if
the legislature makes such a statement
that would be important for ISO New
England to know so it all kind of
connects to to each other yeah but
that's an important Market signal to
send I think yeah I guess it depends on
who you're sending the resolution to you
know really yeah well I guess it would
be to the federal government right I
mean
right yeah yeah I mean from a site
evaluation committee model here in New
Hampshire we have uh nothing in front of
us we are viewed I think as a state
that's not friendly to uh to power
generation of any kind and so if that's
important to the legislature to send a
message to the market that we are open
for business then uh then those kinds of
messages are important
okay it does have some effect as you're
saying it does next time we vote on a
resolution we
yeah people are watching closer than
yeah um oh that uh I don't know if I
mentioned this but on
Monday uh so uh representative Michael
Vose is the chair of the current chair
of science technology energy and he let
me know about a program that's run by
the
national National I want to say Council
but it's not Council conference National
Conference of state
legislators n CSL next week they're
running uh a uh a program on state
nuclear policy so so I'm going to go
down to North Carolina on Monday and
we're gonna talk to other state I have
no idea what to expect but we're
actually going to take a tour of a plant
down there um so I'll report back to the
group you know what what I find out next
week
but and we'll send some signals that
all right so this is a good uh point to
ask is there anything missing from these
recommendations and I'll open it up to
our audience members here our
our um our guests in the in the room um
if you've had a chance just to look at
those 13 items and if there's anything
missing
okay
right there's always going to be
something that was
overlooked all right any anything uh
else you'd like to add to that the only
thing I would say is you
know I've had the opportunity to be like
all over the country over the past year
one of the one of the debates is being
had in it was it had we had the debate
at nud you know
is our markets you know our Market's
broken right now when it comes to
electricity and you know as I spoke to
earlier nothing's getting developed
based on Market revenue for the most
part in New England right they're all
out of Market contracts whether you're
agree or disagree it doesn't matter
that's kind of the facts
um so is that that that conversation is
being had does that bode well for
nuclear or not like
so the more you have out of Market
contracts the more you supress wholesale
market prices right and distorts the
market reduce you guys know all about
this so you know what's the what's the
future look like and we probably can't
get too involved in that but I just
wanted to raise it it's it is an issue
and it is one that again we haven't
developed a nuclear reactor in a
deregulated uh jurisdiction ever so if
it does it have to be because if we're
going to just move forward with all
bilateral PPA you know
contracts I don't know I'm throwing
stuff out there but I mean it's so how
would you how would you put that into I
don't know you know it's it's just I
don't know if it's just a kind of a
sidebar you know there's there's a
discussion about you know our markets
deliver High signals that you know
properly incentivize you know level play
and that's the question that's that's
out there right now and there's and it's
not and it's not partisan you know it's
there's folks that have long supported
markets that are realizing that maybe
they are broken and we need to kind of
look at something else so I don't know I
really know how to put it in into words
I just wanted to raise it with a group
and see if that's something that you
know it's probably a whole separate
discussion but it does impact
nule I think I would just say the
legislature has lots of options
available to them there's unel today is
building a 5 megawatt solar farm you
know and so you could say oh it's okay
to build a 250 megawatt nuclear reactor
I mean the legislature has options
available to it right now they've capped
it at you've capped it at five megawatts
but there's nothing that says you
couldn't change that that's a good you
know and maybe that's a maybe that's a
pro possible policy recommendation to
look at that's going to open a whole can
of worms up just just so you know yeah
it is possible it's in your purview to
change
you could put the genie back in the auto
if you wanted so this you mean the like
re-regulate the market
and you could I mean there serious
discussions being had about it but once
you cross that five megawatt threshold
don't you get into issues with with f
and
other things
Federal I'm sure there would be a a host
of issues to work but
ultimately anything is anything is
possible that's what I would say I mean
I know that five MW number seems to be a
a threshold or or barrier when we're
talking about um net metering and things
like that we see once we rub up against
that we sort of get out of the perview
of
States that's a jurisdictional issue on
compensation right so but if you were
to what the chairman is talking about is
is a rate base issue which you know
generally Falls to St
approv I think yeah I'm not aware of any
federal um limit Mr shock may may know
may want to comment but it's U so far I
I'm not aware I understand um Senator
Pearl what you're talking about with
respect in that metering I'm just not
sure from a sighting perspective there
would be any jurisdictional boundary
that that I know of Mr shock would you
have any
okay David sorry just put your mic on
I'm sorry you don't mind I know it's a
pain yeah we get us once you get outside
of the realm of net metering and instate
compensation regimes yeah that it's not
the five megawatt limit is not quite as
important
okay
so so like let's say let's say that they
passed a law you know allowing for
utilities to build up to 10 megawatts
right let's say uni to to 10 megawatt so
so that's not subject to F jurisdiction
it because it's rate based I mean I know
right
the I don't feel so bad
now I don't think it's a problem for the
utility right right it's
um the the problem with net metering and
that sort of compensation scheme right
um has to do whether it's with whether
it's wholesale transaction that touches
the grid the the
grid so it sounds like there's another
suggestion here I I would need help
putting it together is there a statute
that we could reference that we could
talk about modifying yeah perhaps Mr
shiik and I could collaborate on on
something that would be
unified right so it's the RSA 374
restructuring of the the industry
statute okay um that essentially
required utilities to divest of their
asset assets the nuclear assets went
first um and you know they are otherwise
prohibited from investing and owning uh
those
assets right unless they fall under this
distributed generation exception where
they can build up to five megawatts
exactly yeah so you could in theory call
distributed generation 250 megawatt and
so I mean would you target just for
advanced nuclear would
you
I would um I'm careful not to make
recommendations other than to say what's
possible and and I Mr so of course the
big issue with this is who's responsible
for payment yeah right and it's rate
payers and the last time one of our
utilities constructed a nuclear plant it
went bankrupt and rate payers were
required to pay for those the those
excess costs for years but if we keep it
small right like mro reactor size right
up to 20 megawatts or something then the
risk is low risk that's right just like
the solar farms at 5 megawatts the risk
is pretty low and that's what you're
seeing now is the development of these
smaller solar arrays that are that are
utility owned so you you know you've
kind of implemented that model on a
smaller scale already could fall into
the non non Alternatives too right yeah
that's true so would you guys mind
collaborating on that and uh pull me in
as needed and
we we is that all right I mean it sounds
like something uh concrete that I'm
grasping at concrete things here you
know resol one we'll talk afterwards and
get you get you something okay all right
yeah we can do that all right so I'll
put a 14
here all right so we're almost done it's
um would you mind indulging me in
reading the conclusion because that's
another thing I think with happy to you
yeah and then we'll be done uh all right
conclusion in conclusion a Hampshire May
stand at a critical juncture in its
energy policy having the potential to
become a net exporter of electricity to
the rest of New England throughout
strategic decision making the foundation
of this transformation May lie in
adopting Advanced nuclear energy
technologies that promise to bring
reliable and cost competitive
electricity generation to commercial
realization within the next decade the
analysis conducted by the study
commission reveals significant process
in nuclear energy particular Ally in
developing Advanced reactor Technologies
these new designs offer enhanced
efficiency and safety making nuclear
power more viable and attractive for
large scale energy production by
focusing on these Innovative
Technologies New Hampshire can establish
itself as a leader in the advanced
nuclear sector positioning excuse me
positioning itself as a major
electricity supplier in the regional
market Central to this vision is the
emphasis on cost competitiveness
Advanced nuclear reactors promis to
improve operational efficiencies and
reduce life cycle costs which could be a
potential opportunity for New Hampshire
to produce electricity at a lower cost
than traditional fossil fuel based
sources if this economic Advantage is
realized it could allow our state to
become a net electricity exporter
enabling the sale of clean and firm
Excess power at competitive prices to
neighboring states moreover focusing on
Advanced nuclear energy would align with
broader energy reliability goals nuclear
power plants can provide consistent and
uninterrupted electricity a critical
factor in ensuring a stable and
dependable energy supply for New
Hampshire and the broader New England
region especially during the harsh
Winters we experience
here while the aspect of global warming
is a significant consideration in the
shift towards nuclear energy the focus
of this conclusion is predominantly on
the economic and reliability benefits of
this energy source New Hampshire's
adoption of advanced nuclear
technologies would be a step towards a
more sustainable energy future and a
strategic economic move that can reshape
the st's role in the regional energy
landscape with the foreign policy
decisions public and private focus and
investment in advanced nuclear
technology New Hampshire could transform
its energy sector into a leading
provider of reliable and cost-efficient
electricity becoming a net energy
exporter within New England this move
could benefit the state economically and
contribute to a more stable and
diversified energy Network in the region
so I said energy exporter three times in
there
um I was trying to added on a uh like a
positive you know note so if you could
give me your critiques on that and we
can make some adjustments if needed but
conclusion I have you know they maybe be
trimming one of the net energy exporter
yeah take one of those out you know but
it's I think it strikes the right tone
can you change global warming to climate
change I could do that
yeah but so that paragraph there is that
um so climate change considerations are
driving
nuclear I I think
we're I don't want to speak on behalf of
the entire state but we focus more on
reliability and economic issues um that
seems to be our Focus
but we don't have any
statutory requirements when it comes to
carbon emissions or climate policies
really so I think that's accur it's okay
right the state's policy is all around
cost Effectiveness that the department
of Energy's published so that's that's I
think at the center of what the New
Hampshire policy is
today doesn't mean there aren't other
things to consider but that's the center
of it and the reliability is super
important for where we live right that's
right all right any closing uh thoughts
um thanks everybody for coming today and
uh helping with the Forum but would you
microphone thank you Mr chairman um
representative Alvin C marac County
District
26 and I just wanted to suggest that
maybe you may want to add a glossery to
the end to cover acronyms and stuff like
that something like you know not
everybody knows what Hal is yeah uh and
there may be some technical terms
relating to either nuclear energy or um
the normal electric power industry maybe
20 to 50 terms or something like that
would you mind working on that
um I could okay uh I would need to have
a copy of the I can send you report to
hunt for the words that you've used okay
um and the other thing might be useful
early into the U uh report would be a
simple uh line graph that would uh
compare uh energy levels say from like
megawatt gigawatt terawatt and what
they're useful for you know what what
will a megawatt typically power how much
power does the city of conquer
use uh how many part of the glossery
then um you could have terawatt I'm
sorry to interrupt you you could have we
could have megawatt terawatt and then in
the definition kind of explain well I
was I was thinking of of a little line
graph with little tick marks on there to
point out uh say the output power of the
bow coal
plant um and several other things how
much power the city of conquer uses
anything that people can relate to to uh
just as an idea of of how much power is
used okay um nothing real complicated
can I make a suggestion sure eia has
state level data Maybe we just put a
link in to to to the
eia the US
does and that links to right to New
Hampshire gives a whole bunch of State
specific profiles you know that may be
helpful to the reader could you send me
that L yeah I'll send you the link and
we can put it in somewhere y
so Alvin I appreciate your suggestions
um you you make the same $100 a year
that I do so any help that you can give
would be appreciated okay thank you get
$100 a
year all right do we need to vote on
this or anything or so that would be my
next question um you know we could have
a signature page if everybody wants to
sign it and I thought maybe I mean
in having served on other commissions
you know you know if you're in a if
you're like in a department position
that you may be reluctant to to do that
you know so um that that that would be
one option is we all sign a piece of
paper and we scan it my suggestion we
would just have the chairman put the
report and for the commission so we
could vote on the report um with some
caveats right so when do we have to have
this in it's due in statute it's due
today which is why we have the meeting
today um but
I think uh we could probably stretch
that a couple of days to get to get it
right and I think getting it right's
most important thing can I can I make a
motion to approve with the suggested
amendments yeah is that okay second and
then that's what I was gonna do this
weekend I will make all those changes um
we would need a glossery by then can I
can send you this uh
document
after and then we we'll talk talk after
the meeting on that
um and then I'll track changes I'll
distribute over the weekend I'll
distribute exactly what was changed so
you can quickly scan it a red line
version Red Line
version and then uh and then we'll
release what you know that final product
so would people be willing to check
their email on Saturday and Sunday and
just reply um is that with you and then
we'll get we'll get this released by
Monday does that work for you
Alvin
approach all right do you want to make a
motion um he didn't I second it oh you
did already okay I seconded so all right
it's ready for you any discussion on the
motion all in favor say I I I any
opposed none opposed all right that
wraps it
up three o'clock on the dot thanks
everybody this was uh an interesting
exercise thank you for uh putting in as
much work as you did you carried
9899 probably per of the load here so
that's Bas
Lo he carried the base load the base
load we have to and uh you know the the
website will stay up I'll keep it up for
a couple of years um all the documents
so it's nuclear n. energy all the
meetings are listed there um I got a uh
had to figure out how to do this the uh
official
state uh link you have to request
permission if you want to post more than
one document so I I did get that
permission and in the next couple of
weeks I'm going to migrate all of the
meeting minutes and so forth over to the
state site so it's permanent um so it'll
be in two places so we'll have a you
know a record of all our work um for
posterity
hopefully all right uh motion to adjourn
so move second by Mark all right all in
opposed
I